et si on parlait des moustiques plus
communément appelé sticks vous vous êtes
là j'essaie de dormir s'il ya encore un
moustique dans ma chambre je les exécute
les écraser pas les moustiques ne les
écrase et pas un moustique c'est
magnifique si le moustique est là ceux
qui servent à quelque chose
[Musique]
celui de la nuit s'appelle culek c'est
son petit nom a le culot de vous tourner
autour de l'oreille mais au tourne
autour de votre tête et pourquoi parce
que en fait c'est pas une femelle
c'est un mal le mal est un adulte qui ne
pique pas mais la seule fonction de la
vie c'est la reproduction donc les lacs
l'attend en fait la femelle qui va venir
et sept feux mais qui va venir pascal
bats pour piquer parce qu'un seule la
femelle pique donc quand elle arrive à
côté est belle le mal la croche et en
fait la simulation se déroule à ce
moment là je vous ai apporté une femelle
de moustiques donc la semaine de
moustiquaires a piqué elle va pour
l'utiliser ce qu'on appelle ici impôts
bossis une trompe qui va percer en fait
la peau et va se retrouver dans un
capillaire elle va absorber tout le sens
qu'on va trouver d'autres capillaires
pour remplir en fait ici son abdomen et
ce sens va être digérée pendant quelques
jours elle va être servir en fait à
développer les yeux de moustiques de la
femelle du moustique et ses yeux on fait
d'une fois que les oeufs sont bien
développés les oeufs vont être pendus
sur une surface humide
si le contact de l'eau c'est souvent
éclore et vos données des petites larves
de moustiques et des halles du tap et de
moustiques
[Musique]
tous n'avaient pas l'habitude d'être
piqué vous allez développer une réaction
gros boutons le bouton qui vous démange
là et pourquoi ça c'est parce que la
femelle quant à vous piquer à vous
injecter de la salive et donc vos
systèmes immunitaires va réagir
vis-à-vis de ces molécules qui sont des
molécules étrangères cinq ans attend
plus haut les mains libres double à tout
vent que vous lisez vous droguez les
héros adoré
ceci dit ça peut changer c'est à dire
qu'en fait si vous êtes souvent piqué
par les moustiques de votre maison
au bout d'un certain temps en fait vous
allez vous habituer à la salive des
moustiques de votre maison et donc au
final en fait même si à des moustiques
de votre maison j'allais être piqué mais
vous n'allez pas faire de réaction et
puis vous dites il ya plus de moustiques
dans ma maison en fait finalement non
vous avez toujours des moustiques
d'autres mais on voulait sans témoin
c'est tout je crois que pour les
moustiques
je suis appétissante ils me voient ils
font ça c'est ma came
[Musique]
évidemment face aux moustiques on n'est
pas égaux forcément il ya des poids
mouche sting ya des pauses sont pas un
moustique
en fait il ya certaines personnes qui
vont émaner des molécules qui vont
attirer les moustiques et en fonction
des individus en fonction de ce que vous
avez mangé en fonction de votre état
ces molécules plus ou moins peuvent
varier c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
développé jusqu'à ce jour dès ce qu'on
appelle des répulsifs de façon à avoir
un produit universel qui va marcher sur
toutes les mains tous les moustiques
surtout les pots et dans tous les
continents
[Musique]
soit on sort pas du tout on est à la
maison
donc ça c'est une option que je pense qu
est à écarter à on est surtout en été la
deuxième chose c'est essayer d'évaluer à
quel moment les moustiques qui piquent à
whisky sont à quel moment où son
activité en général les moustiques de
qui assure activités de la journée
épique en début de journée c'est à dire
à l'aube
ensuite aucun puce culot coucher du
soleil donc si on couvrait en fait les
bras et les jambes avec des vêtements
amples en peu limité d'une certaine
façon des piqûres de moustiques
il est là la regarder
[Rires]
[Musique]
la femelle est là ce qu'on appelle des
bourses à l'intérêt de son corps qui va
stocker les spermatozoïdes d'un seul mal
parce que le mal
une fois qu'il a inséminé la femelle va
se retirer et pas l'ubs est un espèce de
bouchons qu'on appelle un bouchon
copulatoire qui va en fait bloqué
l'accès à un éventuel deuxième mal qui
pourrait avoir envie d'assimiler cette
femelle donc une femelle peut vivre
jusqu'à deux mois et elle va pondre
entre 50 et 300 jeux tous les 4-5 jours
[Musique]
j'espère que vous allez avoir des
moustiques tout le temps d'aller avant
des moustiques pendant ont pendant
pendant au moins cette période estivale
et encore on a beaucoup de choses par
rapport aux pays ou régions tropicales
ou là des moustiques toute l'année donc
forcément évitons des asperges et
d'insecticides évitant de générer des
monstres qui m'intéressent histoire aux
insecticides
de toute façon les moustiques qui sont
résistants à tous les ans une biologie
qui va leur permettre de survivre a
beaucoup de choses à plus de choses que
nous donc il était là avant nous ils
vont être là aujourd'hui et vont être là
après nous